it's a friday edition of pft pm joining
us now the man who is in charge of the
nfl's response to an unprecedented
challenge as the pandemic intersects
with
professional football it's chief medical
officer alan
sills joining us this morning dr seal is
great to see you as always how are you
doing
hey i'm doing great mike thanks for
having me hey it's great to have you and
one of the things that i've been kicking
around is i try to
better understand how a pandemic works
and
how a pandemic meshes if at all with
professional sports and we've seen it
play out with different sports over the
past several months
from your perspective i mean you have
spent your life
your professional life focused on brain
health on brain
surgery how hard has it been for you to
pivot
to becoming essentially on the fly an
expert in epidemiology
well mike i'm certainly not becoming an
expert in epidemiology but i think
this is something that's been hard for
all of us in the medical world
none of us have experienced anything
like this before in our medical careers
we've obviously seen in various
epidemics but this one is very unique so
i think that's why it's become very much
a team effort
we've had to certainly for me personally
i've had to lean on the expertise and
advice of many different
people who are infectious disease
experts population health experts
epidemiologists
and certainly my colleagues in sports
medicine around the world
with other professional sports leagues
so we've had to collaborate communicate
with each other because
all of us are in uncharted waters here
and the good news is that we can learn
from each other
and i think that's been one of the very
gratifying things about this pandemic is
this hasn't been about what the nfl is
doing or the nba
this has been about us as a medical
community trying to
proactively address uh what is a very
novel and emerging virus and so
we've had more communication
collaboration than we probably ever had
before
across all of those leagues and all
those different levels of expertise
which league would you say you've
learned the most from
well it'd be hard to say anyone because
every single person has has been very
instructive i mean i think
again i talk regularly each week with
major league baseball with nba with
national hockey league with major league
soccer but we've also talked with
australian football league
with rugby we've talked with the
bundesliga the english premier league so
i have to say mike every single one of
them has has added something and it's
expanded our thinking and again we've
shared in both directions what we're
doing
listening to what they're doing and i
think that communication will continue
how much has it added to the challenge
for the nfl to successfully pull off the
season
given that places like germany where the
bundesliga plays
england or the premier league plays
those places seem to have
as a society done better getting the
virus
under control getting to the other side
the pandemic not that it's gone
but they've handled it better than we
have as a kind how much has that
complicated the effort
to play football in this climate
well i think it's no doubt that the
situation in our country is more
challenging as you mentioned some of
those other countries have done a much
better job or have have had
you know fewer cases and the pandemic is
at a different state
and so it does make our job more complex
in america
but again i think each country is unique
each population is unique each sport is
unique as you know there are different
risk levels and there are different
things we can do to mitigate risk
among our different sports but but i
think we we all clearly realize we have
a huge challenge on our hands this is
really hard
this isn't just hard for us as the nfl
or pro sports this is hard for us as a
country how are we going to try to
navigate our
way through this pandemic and and really
in a sense mike
can we learn to live with this virus
because from what i read in here and see
and i'm sure you do the same things i
don't expect that this is going to go
away or disappear anytime soon
so it's it's not about waiting for that
day when it disappears we all hope that
day is
is not far off but until it does what
can we do to mitigate risk and try to
establish some sense of normalcy around
our lives but do so in a thoughtful and
safe way
i think that's the question that not
just the nfl is trying to answer
other sports leagues but that's what
schools and businesses and places of
worship
we all have that very same objective and
that very same challenge
i agree with you completely on that
point that we have to assume
it's going to hang around maybe for
multiple nfl seasons
and you're in a far better position than
i am to understand the issues
to grasp the nuances but the one thing
to me that seems to be
the topic that would most affect
the nfl point of care testing when
point-of-care testing is available
at a sufficiently high accuracy rate
where you can essentially set up a
barrier
into the team facility into the stadium
onto the bus
onto the plane wherever you decide to
have the testing
that gives you a result then and there
positive or negative that you can trust
that seems to be the thing that will
change everything for the nfl am i wrong
in
thinking that well i i would agree and
disagree with part of that and let me
explain
absolutely we would all love to have
accurate immediate
uh of the widely available point of care
testing again that's not just something
in the nfl that's across our medical
enterprise
is everyone would like to have a more
accurate more widely available tests so
full stop that will be a step forward
for everyone
but i think we also have to recognize
what the limitations of testing are
testing is not prevention testing is
about containment
so testing doesn't prevent you from
getting the virus in the first place
what prevents you from getting the virus
are things like wearing a mask
physical distancing staying away from
sick people staying home if you're sick
staying away from crowded places
and all of those risk mitigation
strategies are not going to change no
matter what the status of testing
is so testing is important it's
certainly something that's part of a
chain but but i think of all these
different links in the chain and there
are many other links that i think are
are equally important with testing so
love to see point of care test available
but it's not going to change that
fundamental
need to still do all those other things
that keep people safe because
masks distancing staying home when
you're sick staying away from sick
people those things are about prevention
testing is about containment but as it
currently stands when you've got a
24-hour lag between sample collection
and test result
if you have somebody who had been
negative negative negative
you find out tomorrow that today is the
day he's positive
ideally that is a doughnut hole that the
nfl would love to close
no question would love to close that but
i'd go back again and say
if in that 24 hour period that you
mentioned that individual has stayed
physically distant has worn a mass
done all of those things then then again
there should be a margin of safety there
for the individual and for the others
and that's why we have to recognize mike
in medicine there's almost no test
that's going to be 100
accurate all the time so even as these
tests get better and better
we still have to realize hey the test
could be wrong it could be a false
negative
so that's why we still have to do all of
those other measures and protect
ourselves no matter what the test
results are telling us
and by all accounts the measures that
have been put in place
at the various teams are excellent i
remember seeing the memo that was
distributed
to the teams june 7 with the first cut
of what the protocols would be
and it is detailed it is thorough and it
creates a sense
that the team facilities will be
safe the traveling squad
when you go on the bus the plane to the
hotels it will be safe at the stadium
everyone will be safe but then at some
point football gets played
and that's the juxtaposition that i
struggle with the most
that we can cross every t and dot
every eye and keep everyone apart and
wear masks and be safe
but then it's eleven on eleventh fall
with guys lined up right across from
each other breathing and sweating and
spitting
and bleeding and how do we reconcile
all the things we're doing to keep guys
safe for the 153 hours a week they're
not in a game
and then to keep them safe for the three
hours when they're out there
in that mix of other human beings who
may be positive and we just don't know
it yet
you know i think you framed it exactly
right if we can do everything right in
those 153 hours leading up to the game
then that's going to make it safer
during that three-hour period because
we're hopefully going to arrive at the
field with everyone who's not
infected and so you exactly described it
doing it right all the time leading up
to the game is what helps us get to the
game
site with hopefully no infections and
anyone that's participating
and in the same way that's why we'll do
pregame testing again to try to add to
that that knowledge base but
but we've said all along mike you're
right physical distance and football
they don't go together
you can't play football and be
physically distant or at least you can't
play it very well in most positions
so i think you have to to look at how do
we arrive there in an uninfected state
and then certainly we will look at and
learn from what happens on the field as
well i do think there's some things you
can do during that three-hour period how
you construct your benches
what people do when they're off the
field you know minimizing risks at other
times in and around who's in that
environment who's coming through the
bench area those things are all going to
matter
the other thing we have to recognize is
we'll continue to learn from other
sports leagues here as i mentioned we've
talked with for example australian
football with rugby
they're not exact parallels to nfl
football but there but there's a lot of
face-to-face contact and in those sports
with unhelmeted players
so we'll take away some learnings from
that and and today
you know knock on wood they've not seen
on field transmission but but i think
it's something we have to continue to be
vigilant about
we'll also get a lot of data you'll
heard about those chips that we're using
for proximity tracing
and we'll understand a lot more about
the interactions on the field who really
is around
who and for what period of time so it is
clearly a vulnerability and something we
have to
continue to address as aggressively as
we can
and there's an avalanche of information
out there about this virus it's
impossible to keep up with it but one
thing that has landed on my radar screen
and i know that there's a belief in some
leaked circles that this will be true
that on field transmission either in an
open air stadium or in a dome that has a
state-of-the-art ventilation system
that that is going to be far more
difficult than transmission in a
confined
space indoors how confident are we as of
right now that there will be a
significant difference between
transmission rates in a building versus
transmission rates on a football field
well mike i think like you said a lot of
experts that i talk to feel like that'll
be the case but the the reality is
we're still learning about that we we
don't have a season of football or any
evening games to to sort of
vet that hypothesis that has been the
experience of these other sports leagues
around the world that i mentioned that
have started up
and again i think the the population
health and epidemiology experts i talked
to they do believe that these open-air
environments as you said either inside
or outside in the ventilation that it
will help
so again i think it's there's a lot
there that that we can be
somewhat reassured by but there's going
to be no substitute for us actually
getting into it gathering the data
looking at it very carefully and then
adjusting i think mike one of the things
we've said throughout is we're going to
have to be flexible and adaptable
because we're going to continue to learn
things not only from our own experience
but from these other leagues
and as we learn those things we'll have
to fine-tune what we're doing
you mentioned all those protocols and we
spent hours and hours and hours
putting those together with a wide
variety of experts but those protocols
will change they'll grow and they'll
develop and they'll get better
that's kind of the nature of medicine is
we're always learning and improving and
i think that'll be the case here
one other issue as we look for potential
risks that would either bring the virus
to the facility or take the virus
out of the facility if an outbreak
happens is the concept
of players going home every night and i
know that a
full league-wide bubble like the nba and
the nhl are doing is completely
impractical too many teams too many
people
too much time too much expense doesn't
make sense
has any thought been given to the
possibility of hardening the bubble
around the 32 teams i know this would be
a major hardship for the players and
their families and the coaches and their
families
but basically sequestering the team from
the rest of the world staying in a
facility staying in a hotel
matt ryan the falcons quarterback told
us the other day they have town houses
at their facility where they have
individual
bathrooms and changing areas and beds
has there been
any thought been given to the
possibility of having a hard bubble
around the 32 teams
and having the players and the coaches
and everyone else who's essential to the
operation
be there all season long without ever
leaving
well we've certainly talked about and
debated every idea
including that idea and been very try to
be very open-minded and thoughtful about
that and we've looked at a
a number of different scenarios and i
think we landed on something that we
feel
combines the margin of safety with the
practicality that you mentioned
but i like to describe what we're doing
is is what we call a virtual football
bubble which means
when guys are at the facility we know
that we've got the protocols we've got
everything in place
we've done a lot of work and together
with the players association around
education what do you do when you leave
the facility and it's our hope that
players coaches and staff because again
this isn't just about
players it's about everybody that they
are going to primarily go home
it's not to say they're never going to
leave their homes but they're when they
do go out they're going to use the
appropriate preventive measures
and do all they can to keep themselves
safe so in a sense it's
it is that bubble concept but it's just
extended out to each individual player's
environment
and again as you point out you have to
rely on each person to make really
important choices about what they do
and trying to mitigate risk for
themselves but i would just point back
mike again to being flexible and
adaptable as we get into the season and
we see what the data shows us
we're going to remain open to all these
different scenarios and seeing what
seems to be the most effective
so you're saying there is a possibility
at some point if there are outbreaks
that
there could be a sequestration of
players and coaches and teams in a hotel
or in a facility
i think all options are on the table
we've said that we are going to continue
to evaluate at every point and do what's
safest for
for everyone involved and so i you know
best way i can answer that is to say all
options remain on the table
and we'll have to deal with each
situation as it comes up and what we
think is the
safest and most thoughtful way last one
for you and i appreciate you giving us
so much time today as it relates to the
current model the virtual bubble as you
explained it
with players going home at the end of
the day how much
of the success or failure of that model
hinges on whether or not schools are
open because the player can do all the
right things
but they have kids that are in school
and they're at school and they get the
virus and bring it home
player gets the virus and brings it to
the facility 24-hour lag between
sample collection and test result the
virus has gotten into the building
yeah it's a great question mike and
again it's something that's still being
studied again not just for an nfl
setting but you know how frequently are
kids vectors and how do they transmit
what do those rates look like
and even within households this is
something that's still somewhat of a
mystery about this virus
you would think that if someone in the
household is infected that 100 of those
close contacts in the household would
get infected and that doesn't seem to
happen
and we don't really understand why why
is it that in some situations
everyone in the house is completely safe
and in other situations they become
infected so
so it is a vulnerability i think again
we've done a tremendous amount of
education as has the players association
to players and their families for
example i've been on several zoom calls
just this week with
with organizations where it was players
and families gathered together and we've
talked with
with spouses and and you know household
cohabitants and children about these
issues
and everyone is going to be in this
together in the sense of trying to make
these good choices and do what they can
to mitigate risks so
again it is very much more so than ever
it's not trying to say this is a team
effort and
every single person in that team
ecosystem is going to have
responsibility to each other person
that's one thing that's been very
encouraging to me as the players return
and the coaches send a message and the
players send the message
the more guys buy into it and their
families buy into it and understand
that everyone needs to be buttoned up
across the board for this to work
hopefully that will happen
hopefully we'll get our 256 regular
season games 13 postseason games
with minimal outbreaks for sales we
appreciate your time today we wish you
all the best as you
embark on a challenge that no nfl chief
medical officer has ever embarked on we
wish you the best with that we hope to
talk to you down the road
hey thanks very much appreciate it best
wishes to you and i'll look forward to
catching up down the road
all right take care hi i'm mike tarico
and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports